I feel like that saying if they say you
can make it in New York you can make it
anywhere
I am from Brooklyn so I feel like I can
do anything my name is Carter Clinton
and I'm a genetic anthropologist and a
National Geographic Explorer presently
one of the major issues that we find in
genomic research is the lack of
representation for african-americans
genomic research is the study of all of
your genes at a basic level and one of
the major goals of this project was to
contribute information from historic
african-american population soil has a
lot of Secrets that you can't see with
the naked eye I'm studying for
hundred-year-old grave so to learn more
about the health and lifestyles of a
historic african-american population
[Music]
this is the New York African burial
ground it's now a National Monument in
1991 a construction crew attempted to
erect federal building at 290 Broadway
being one of the taller buildings in the
area was about 30 stories high they had
to dig 30 feet below and around 25 feet
they began to uncover and unearth human
remains after they found the human
remains they went back to the historical
maps they realized that they had just
rediscovered the New York African burial
ground 419 were excavated and that's out
of an estimated 15,000 individuals over
6.6 acres of land so here we have the
New York African burial ground Greystoke
collection housed at Howard University
and each of the samples represents an
individual who is buried 400 years ago
and each sample is collected from a
specific body region from each of those
individuals
so we each have our own unique bacterial
community or signature if you will of
bacteria that live within us on us like
on our skin and our gut when we die that
bacteria is the leading force in how our
bodies are decomposed so what we're
looking at is what survives after 400
years after a person has been buried so
we took the original soil samples we
saved it we collected that those fine
particles and then we attempted a DNA
extraction so we did that hundreds of
times over the span of about six months
and then one day we actually got results
it was the best day ever this is the
best day ever
so even hundreds of years after a person
passes away you can see infectious
disease bacteria that may be the result
of what that person died from
I feel proud I feel proud to be an
african-american working on what could
be what could possibly be my direct
ancestors being an african-american and
native New Yorker at the same time it's
so much more than just the tangible it's
the knowledge that you had ancestors who
lived years ago that contributed to this
greater picture that you're now part of
so we're not just contributing the
science we're contributing the history
[Music]
[Music]